fatuma adan couseau and her two children
are among 900 000 people displaced by
drought in somalia she's carried her
children for more than 300 kilometers to
reach humanitarian aid provided by the
u.n
when we finished our stock of food from
the farm and animals started dying we
could not feed our children we decided
to flee because of hunger
according to the united nations the horn
of africa is suffering its longest
drought in four decades in somalia it
says millions of people are facing
famine and more than 3 million animals
essential to farming communities have
died
crop production has also substantially
dropped due to drought
the number of people now in need of
urgent humanitarian assistance has
increased from around 4 million at the
start of the year to more than 7 million
our focus is very much on livelihoods
it's providing cash to allow people to
buy food to survive it's about keeping
their animals alive with emergency
feeding with
vet treatments
with water supplies for animals in a
drought context which is super important
the brave commander is heading to
djibouti carrying 23 000 metric tons of
wheat that will be transferred to
ethiopia one of five countries the u.n
deems at risk of starvation
this is the beginning we hope of more
normal operations
the food of ukraine fed 400 million
people across the world last year
wfp purchased 880 000 metric tons and we
moved that food to somalia yemen
ethiopia
sudan
the mission comes after russia and
ukraine agreed to a deal with turkey
last month to restart grain deliveries
across the black sea
the u.n ship is the first to set sail
for africa carrying grain from ukraine
since russia invaded the country
providing much needed relief for those
suffering from drought in the horn of
africa
jillian wolf al jazeera